Imagine for a second just picture handing an unreleased frontier AI the actual keys to the world's open source code. Right. You aren't just telling it to, you know, take a look around. You are explicitly
instructing it to find every single locked door that someone accidentally forgot to shut.
Which is exactly what happened.
Exactly. when a massive vulnerability research initiative they called it project glasswing when they did exactly this in early 2026 using anthropics claude mythos preview model the ai didn't just find like
a handful of bugs
not at all
it flagged twenty three thousand and nineteen latent vulnerabilities i mean over six thousand of those were initially rated as high or critical severity
And, you know, it's important to point out that it wasn't just hallucinating those threats,
right? Yeah.
When independent security firms, along with Anthropic's own internal teams, when they pulled a batch of about 1,700 findings to actually manually verify them, the validation rate was over 90%.
That is just wild.
It really is. Yeah. And more than 60% were confirmed as genuinely high or critical. I mean, the AI was basically operating as this nearly perfect digital guard dog. It was reasoning through these incredibly
complex intertwined code bases at a scale that human engineers simply, well, they just cannot match.
Which, you know, sounds like the ultimate defensive shield for you and me. You find the holes, you patch them, we all sleep a little better at night.
Exactly.
But here's the totally terrifying flip side for your digital infrastructure. Just seven months prior to that, that exact same family of technology was deployed offensively.
Yeah, that's the cache.
Its own developer actually called it the first largely autonomous cyber espionage campaign because the exact same capability that finds a vulnerability for a defender to patch. Well, it can find it for an attacker to exploit. Finding the lock and picking the lock, it turns
out, require the exact same intelligence.
And this is really the defining dual use dilemma that policymakers are facing right now. I mean, when the tool that secures the network is functionally identical to the tool that dismantles it, how do you release it safely?
Right. And right now, governments are essentially just throwing spaghetti at the wall to see what sticks.
Pretty much.
Like Executive Order 14409 in the U.S. sets up this voluntary framework. It asks AI labs to give the government up to 30 days of early access before a model goes to other trusted partners. But then meanwhile, California's
SB53 leans really heavily into transparency, just hoping public scrutiny keeps developers in line. New York's RAISE Act is out there threatening civil penalties. And over in Europe, the revised EU Product Liability Directive is really
bringing the hammer down, extending strict liability to standalone software so developers actually have to pay for the damage their models cause.
So it's like every jurisdiction is just yanking a completely different lever.
Yes.
But very few of them are actually asking how these lethal and temporal levers interact like mathematically in a world where AI operates at machine speed.
Which brings us to the actual core of today's deep dive. We are unpacking a brand new paper just came out in August 2026 by economist Joshua S. Gans. It's titled Staged Access and Liability for Dual Use Artificial Intelligence.
A fantastic paper.
Really is. Ganz argues that the current policy debates are treating all these laws as totally isolated solutions. Like he looks at that 30 day voluntary window from the U.S. government and just points out that it's well, it's just a
round number.
Right. It's arbitrary.
Exactly. It wasn't calibrated from any sort of mathematical model of the actual cyber contest it's supposed to be influencing.
And that's because Gans approaches this not just as a pure technology problem, but as an economic contest over a finite resource.
OK.
But to really appreciate his solution, we should probably trace how the academic consensus on. handling dangerous information, you know, how it actually evolved to reach this point.
Oh, totally. Because it used to be just a super simple binary, right? Publish or perish. If a researcher found a new way to exploit a server, the entire debate was literally just about whether to publish the paper or bury it.
Yeah, and that began to change pretty significantly around 2022.
Okay.
There was a researcher named Toby Shevlin, and he introduced this concept of structured access.
Right, structured access.
Yeah, so Shevlin basically argued that since AI models are interactive tools, the whole paradigm had to shift from what information to publish to who actually gets to use the model and how.
Oh. This
introduced the whole era of ongoing control regimes that are run through cloud services rather than just dumping open source models out into the world.
But even with a heavily monitored cloud service, you're assuming that just keeping an eye on the user is enough to prevent harm.
Exactly.
And there's this July 2026 paper, The Oracle's Gambit by Landall and colleagues that just fundamentally shatters that assumption. They looked at this through the lens of computer science and realized that even controlled simultaneous access is basically a
disaster for the defender.
Yeah. Landall models the release of a dual use AI as a bi-level Stackelberg game. It's a game theory term, but basically the old cybersecurity norm, the 90 day responsible disclosure window that Aurora and others
formalized. It relied on a very specific human limitation. What was the limitation? Well, if a defender found a flaw, they had 90 days to patch it because human adversaries simply couldn't cheaply or quickly rediscover that exact same
vulnerability.
Oh, right. Because the human brain was the bottleneck.
Exactly.
But if I'm a malicious actor today and I have the same frontier AI as the defender. I mean, I don't need 90 days to manually dig through the code. I can just unleash the model to hunt for zero days immediately. So that capability gap completely vanishes.
And that loss of the capability gap, that is what Landolt describes as a Red Queen's race.
Like from Alice in Wonderland, running just to stay in the same place.
Exactly that. The defender's welfare doesn't improve just because their absolute capability goes up. I mean, if the attacker's capability goes up by the exact same amount at the exact same time, handing a model to both sides simultaneously just traps the defender in this
accelerated war they can't possibly win.
Oh, wow.
So Landahl concludes that the most crucial lever isn't deciding whether to deploy or withhold a model. It's the sequencing of access. You absolutely have to create a protective gap by pre-releasing to the defender alone.
OK, but let me just pause and play devil's advocate here or just challenge the underlying premise. Sure. If this is a race, maybe the bad guys are already driving a totally different vehicle. Like there is a massive faction of researchers pushing back against
this entire panic narrative.
Yes. And that is a critical tension we really have to acknowledge. Like in 2024, Sayyash Kapoor and a pretty large group of co-authors published this paper on the societal impact of open foundation models. And they utilize what they call a
marginal risk framework.
Right. And to be completely clear to you listening, we aren't taking sides here. We just want to lay out the arguments fairly.
Absolutely.
So they basically ask, how much additional risk does an open release actually create relative to the technology that already exists out there? Right. Because, I mean, if I want to launch a cyber attack today, I don't need a frontier AI. I can already buy bespoke malware and exploitation tools on the
dark web. So Kapoor's verdict across these different misuse vectors is that the evidence for AI drastically increasing that baseline risk is just really thin and often highly overstated.
And, you know, if you subscribe entirely to Kapoor's view, the complex regulatory models we are discussing might seem completely unnecessary.
Yeah. Why bother regulating it if it's not adding risk?
Exactly. But Gans builds his economic theory on the explicit assumption that the adversary does genuinely gain a new, very dangerous edge at release. And given the autonomous espionage campaigns we've already witnessed, policymakers are treating that specific
threat as very, very real.
Right. They have to. And if the threat is real, the natural instinct for a lot of people is to just, you know, pull the emergency brake on the whole industry. Right. That's what those MIT researchers, Ko and Sang-Won Moo, proposed in their 2026 paper on technology speed limits. They
actually argue for an adaptive cap on how fast a technology can computationally scale over a given unit of time.
Yeah. And their mathematical proofs basically show that if learning about a danger inherently requires time, capping the capability growth is a robustly optimal strategy.
But a speed limit dictates how fast the entire industry's capability can grow. Gantz is tackling something much more surgical, isn't he? I mean, he isn't trying to slow down the overarching march of technology itself. He is arguing for a committed calendar date
for the release of one specific model and pairing that with liability.
Exactly. And this brings us right into the real machinery of Ganz's paper. He does this brilliant thing where he collapses a wildly complex dynamic hacking war into a simple repetitive game. He calls it the flaw contest.
The flaw contest. So both the defender and the adversary are basically searching the exact same hidden stock of latent flaws in a piece of software.
Yes. And when a flaw is found, it leaves the pool. Either the defender patches it or the adversary exploits it.
Right. It's gone either way.
Right. Gans terms this winner independence. Which essentially means the game board resets the exact same way regardless of who won the last round.
Why?
They're just dividing up a finite stock of vulnerabilities.
Okay, wait. If they're just competing over a finite pool, then the EU's approach of strict liability seems like the completely obvious silver bullet.
You'd think so.
Like, just make the AI developer face massive civil penalties for any harm their model causes. My immediate reaction as a developer would be to just throw infinite compute at finding those bugs before launch to avoid the fine.
Problem solved, right? So why is Gans saying liability alone is actually a trap at release?
Because the adversary is reacting to your defense.
Oh.
Imagine a regulator doubles the liability penalty, right? The developer totally panics and searches twice as hard to drain that hidden pool of flaws.
Okay, so the defender is finding bugs way faster.
Right, but the adversary is watching this happen. They realize the potential prize pool of exploitable vulnerabilities is shrinking really rapidly. So what do they do? the adversary ramps up their own search effort to capture their share before the defender scoops it all up.
Oh, I see. It's literally like a tug of war.
Exactly.
Pulling harder on the rope just signals your opponent to brace and pull harder against you, so you burn twice the energy, but the rope barely even moves.
That is the exact mathematical dynamic. Ganz shows that the pass-through of liability is bounded below one half.
Meaning what exactly?
Meaning if you double the liability rate on the developer, you cut the share of exploited flaws by less than half. The adversary's reaction partially cancels out your policy.
Wow. Okay, so if the attacker just fights back, how does exclusivity, giving the defender a time window before the attacker even gets the model, how does that fix the trap?
Because before release, the adversary has no comparable AI capability to fight back with. This is the central asymmetry the entire paper turns on.
Okay, let's untack that.
After release, liability strengthens both sides because of that tug-of-war effect. But before release, liability strengthens only the defender.
Because the attacker is still stuck using human speeds or just older tools?
Yes. So
the extra defensive search that the liability threat forces the developer to buy is completely uncontested?
Precisely. And this is why Gans argues that staged access and liability are complements, not substitutes. Liability provides the financial pressure to search, and exclusivity ensures that search is actually effective without triggering a massive counter-escalation.
That actually makes total sense. But what does the defender's actual workflow look like during that exclusive early access window? Like, if I have 30 days, my instinct is that I run a massive constant level of compute every single day to maximize my haul.
You would naturally think so, yeah.
Yeah.
But Gans pulls a fascinating mechanism from labor economics to prove otherwise. He actually borrows from Dale Mortensen's 1977 work on job search and benefit exhaustion.
Okay, so what does Mortensen say?
He shows that during the exclusive window, the defender's search effort is not constant at all.
Wait, why wouldn't it be?
It comes down to the shadow value of a missed flaw. Imagine it's day one of a 30-day window. If the defender misses a latent bug today, the urgency is incredibly low because they still have 29 days of uncontested access to catch it later.
Right. But as the clock ticks down, that reserve of exclusive calendar starts running out.
Exactly. And the margin for error just completely disappears. If you miss a flaw on day 29, the adversary gets the frontier model tomorrow and the tug of war begins. Therefore, defensive search effort rises steadily as the window progresses, and it hits
its absolute maximum intensity exactly on the day of release.
It's like the ultimate college student cramming for a final exam.
Totally.
You have a whole month to study, but the deadline dictates the urgency. So you end up doing the vast majority of the real work in the last 72 hours.
And that economic reality leads to a highly counterintuitive consequence for regulators. When a new model seems exceptionally dangerous, a policymaker's first instinct is always to extend the window.
Right. They think if 30 days is good, 90 days must be three times as safe. Let's push it back.
But if the effort curve is heavily backloaded, postponing the release date just adds time at the very beginning of the window.
Where search effort is at its absolute weakest.
Exactly. The urgency drops because the deadline is further away. So extra delay becomes progressively less productive. Gans proves mathematically that optimal evaluation windows are inherently bounded.
So there's a limit.
Yes. The political logic of the danger is worse so we must wait longer eventually just runs out of road.
So the calendar alone isn't the metric we should care about. It's the intensity of the search multiplied by the time we grant it.
Yes. Gantz calls this protection depth. The exclusive window doesn't change who wins the contest on the flaws that remain after a lease. What it does is aggressively reduce how much remains to be contested in the first place.
Headway is drawdown.
So if protection debt is the true goal here, Gantz has some results that are going to deeply frustrate lawmakers who are drafting these bills, right? Particularly regarding how high those financial penalties should be.
Oh, absolutely. The standard legal intuition, which we see reflected heavily in EU policy discussions, is that a developer should fully internalize the cost of the harm their product causes.
Right. 100% liability. You break it, you buy it.
But Gantz proves the efficient liability rate is actually partial. It should be strictly below full compensation.
Wait, I really want to unpack the logic there. Because forcing a massive tech company to pay for all the damage their AI causes is super politically popular. Why would a top economist mathematically prove that's a mistake?
Because defensive search burns real world resources. We are talking about massive compute clusters, extraordinary energy consumption, and highly, highly speculized human capital.
Right, it's not free of search.
Exactly. If a developer faces 100% liability, they will overinvest in defense. They will burn through more societal resources trying to find deeply hidden marginal flaws than the flaws themselves would
have actually cost society if they were just left alone.
So the cure literally becomes more expensive than the disease. Yes. So a partial liability rate prevents them from wasting compute on diminishing returns. OK, but what about the calendar itself? Because Landolt's paper suggested that if you just leave the AI labs alone, they will rationally
balance this trade off themselves and naturally choose the right release window.
And Gans completely dismantles that assumption.
Really?
Yeah. He shows that a developer left to pick their own calendar will naturally use the timeline to evade liability. Their private financial incentives simply do not align with the social optimum. They will almost never choose the regulator's preferred release date.
Which leaves a distinct, basically necessary job for a government timing mandate. You cannot rely on voluntary commitments or liability alone. You absolutely need both.
They must be designed together. But, you know, we also really have to highlight the honest limits of Ganz's theory here.
Right. Because it is just a theory.
Right. And every economic model makes simplifying assumptions to make the math
work.
The baseline of this paper assumes instantaneous patching.
Meaning the second the AI finds the bug, the bug is magically fixed and removed from the board.
Exactly. But in the physical reality of software engineering, that is rarely true. Let's look back at Project Glasswing from our introduction. The AI found over 6,000 critical flaws almost immediately.
Right.
But it took human developers an average of two full weeks just to create the patches, let alone deploy them across all those fragmented networks.
A two-week lag.
Right.
Wow. So if I find a critical vulnerability on day 28 of a 30-day exclusive window, finding it is completely useless. The adversary gets the model on day 30, and my patch won't even be ready for another 12 days.
The human element introduces a totally catastrophic lag. remediation takes real time. If the window doesn't account for the speed of human bureaucracy and engineering, the protective gap basically collapses. SARAH
BALDWIN- OK, so bringing this all together for you listening, the public debate around AI regulation is almost always presented as this really stark binary choice. We are told to either release everything openly so innovation thrives or hoard the
models in bunkers so the grid doesn't collapse. We are told to either regulate the industry into the ground or just let the court sort out the damages after the fact.
And Joshua Gann's argument is that both of those framings are entirely wrong.
The real levers of power are a specific calendar date and a partial liability rate calibrated together.
Exactly.
A liability rate without an exclusive window just creates a useless, wildly expensive tug of war. A window without liability means the developer has no financial incentive to pay for the massive compute needed to search for the bugs in the first place.
They are compliments, yeah.
And that voluntary 30-day window the U.S. government suggested, it is just a round number that nobody bothered to actually calibrate to the capabilities of the AI. The math suggests the optimal window is finite and honestly likely shorter than our intuition
dictates because adding time doesn't proportionally add effort.
Which leaves a profoundly disturbing open question for you to consider as these frontier models continue to scale up.
Yeah.
Gantz provides this incredibly elegant theory for a perfect regulatory framework. But if AI models reach a point where they can detect millions of latent vulnerabilities across our entire digital infrastructure in seconds, while human bureaucracies still take
weeks to write and deploy a single patch, does the speed of human remediation ultimately render any regulatory head start completely meaningless?
Could we achieve perfectly calibrated protection depth on paper while suffering total systemic failure in practice? It's definitely something to keep you awake tonight.
Until next time.